the Director General dr. Ted Rose dear
friends of the World Health Organization
in the last three months we all have
seen how crucial it is to join forces
for our individual and collective health
only two weeks after the first corona
virus outbreak laboratories across the
world from South Korea to Germany were
able to work on the full sequence of the
corona virus genome and in a matter of
days
they developed a test for the virus that
was possible because of the share of
information on a global scale in times
of a global pandemic international
cooperation should be a no-brainer now
is the time to act we need to fight and
defeat coronavirus and all continents we
need tests medicines and vaccines and we
need them to be affordable for all last
month you called on all nations to join
forces so that a cure and vaccine could
not only be developed but distributed
all across the world the European Union
responded immediately we hosted a
virtual pledging conference raising
eight billion dollar we put Europe's
convening power at the service of the
United Nations system and of all
humankind this will accelerate the
development of much-needed vaccines and
therapeutics and we will see to it that
once developed they can be deployed
universally and be available to all a
corona virus vaccine should not be a
luxury for choosing few but a universal
common good let me thank the co-sponsors
and all of you for our good cooperation
in times like these the greatest act of
courage is to play as a team this does
not mean that once the dust will have
settled and once we have delivered on
our pledge to beat this virus we should
not look into ways to modernize
wh Oh to see what should be done for the
wh o to continue to live up to the new
challenges because we need multilateral
approaches but let us for now focus on
our most immediate challenge this is the
time for cooperation this is the time
for science and solidarity this is the
time for all humanity to rally around
the common cause and you can count on
Europe to always play for the team